[Music]
the heads of these golf clubs are made
from aerospace grade stainless steel to
produce them the factory begins with a
wax replica of the club head to make
this wax pattern as it's called they
inject hot wax into a mold they extract
the pattern and snip off the bulk of the
excess wax using hot wax as an adhesive
a robot joins several patterns to other
wax parts in the shape of gates and
runners the term for the channels that
guide molten metal into the casting mold
[Music]
then the robot dips these patterns into
liquid ceramic material four times with
a shower of silica sand in between each
coat the ceramic and sand hardened
forming the shell around the wax
patterns then the factory melts out the
wax the shell is now a mold with which
to cast the metal Club heads on the
casting floor a furnace heats steel bars
to 3000 degrees Fahrenheit well beyond
the melting point the pouring technique
is critical the metal must flow at a
consistent rate to prevent the formation
of air bubbles after 5 hours a pneumatic
hammer breaks apart the mold workers
sawed off the gates and runners
separating the club heads then they
grind off the last remnants of the gates
and runners
a turntable runs the club heads through
a sandblaster which gives the metal a
particular finish next they stick on a
metal bag bearing the club's model name
they apply a guide of automotive paint
the color identifies the angle of the
club there are 12 different angles
[Music]
now they line the neck of the club head
with epoxy then coat the end of the
shaft with epoxy and slip it into the
neck a pneumatic hammer pushes the shaft
in as far as it can go this shaft is
made of either extruded steel or carbon
fiber now it's time to work on the shaft
first they cut it to the right length
depending on the model then they put the
shaft on a spindle and wrap the top 10
inches in double-sided tape to hold the
clubs rubber grip
they lubricate the tape and the inside
of the grip before sliding the grip over
the shaft a laser line helps them align
the grip in the right position this is
critical because the grip is the golfers
guide to correct hand positioning which
is essential to a good swing next a
computer reads the lie the term for the
club head's angle relative to the ground
then it reads the loft the term for the
angle of the club head's face the
computer then tells the technician what
adjustments to make once he's made the
adjustments the computer reanalyze --is
the new loft and lie to ensure they're
perfect it's this type of precision that
ensured these golf clubs for the quality
specifications to a tee
[Music]